[Музика]
привіт, хлопці, мене звуть Наталія спавн,
пора уроку англійської мови, давайте розпочнемо, тому
сьогодні ми продовжимо розмову про
різні типи книг та літератури,
давайте, так що ми читаємо, що ви
пам'ятаєте з попереднього уроку, давайте
намалюємо  павук Ґрем, то які
матеріали для читання читати, і ми читаємо
книги,
що ще веб-сайти,
комікси, що ще, ми також читаємо електронні книги,
що стосується газет і журналів, добре,
тому ми також описали різні типи
книг, будь ласка, нагадайте мені, що це таке, щоб
це було  будь роман книга жахи
пригоди
науково-фантастичний кримінальний
трилер що ще біографія та інші
так нагадай мені з попередніх уроків я
поклав книгу кудись тут, так чи пам'ятаєш ти,
що тут було
так романтика в моїх руках пригода, ніж
тут кримінальний трилер і тут була
біографія і  як щодо найпопулярнішої
наукової фантастики
Браво, тож давайте далі, для вас є завдання,
подивіться на визначення та
напишіть, будь ласка, тип книги  так
дивіться книги про реальні факти та події
книга про життя відомої людини
відома старовинна книга захоплююча книга
про незаконну діяльність історія кохання
дуже страшна історія історія, повна
хвилювання вибори та небезпеки історія
про майбутнє  простір та історія,
створена з чиєїсь уяви, тож
давайте разом перевіримо
номер один реальні факти чи події так
документальна література книга про життя
відомої людини це біографія добре
зроблена добре відома стара книга це класичний
роман наступний захоплюючий  книга
про незаконну діяльність що це так
кримінальний трилер історія кохання
роман молодець дуже лякаюча
страшна історія жах Браво наступна
історія, повна хвилювання
, дії та небезпеки так це
пригода історія про майбутнє чи
космос це наукова фантастика  так справжня
подяка та події нехудожня література майбутній
космос це наукова фантастика та
історія, створена з чиєїсь
уяви, це чудова фантастична книга
давайте поговоримо про  Але домашнє завдання я
попросив вас написати подібний діалог, тому
подивіться на модель, і ви
повинні написати діалог за фантастичним романом «
Заводний ангел» Кассандри Клер,
давайте подивимося на відповідь, тож це
приклад для вас, тож давайте прочитаємо  разом
що ви читаєте в Анжелі це
фантастичний роман під назвою «Заводний ангел»
Кассандри Клер, про що йдеться у ньому
про підлітка, який намагається врятувати
світ, це добре так, це фантастично, мені це
дуже подобається, зараз давайте прочитаємо
діалог разом я»  я буду А, а
ти будеш Б, тож ти читай зі мною,
що ти читаєш в Анжелі,
про що
йдеться, це добре,
дякую, тепер давайте поміняємося ролями, що ти
, а я буду Б, щоб ти  почніть
читати
це фантастичний роман під назвою «Заводний
ангел» Кассандри Клер, це про
підлітка, який намагається врятувати світ так,
це фантастично, мені це дуже подобається,
дуже дякую, давайте рухаємося далі. У мене
є завдання для вас подивіться, у нас
діалог  подібний діалог але го  Є
фрази відсутні, тому допоможіть мені, що
буде номером один так, що ви
читаєте Ненсі,
це фантастичний роман Ніла Джаміна «Зоряний пил»,
номер два, про що йдеться
правильно, це про молодого чоловіка, який
шукає впалу зірку, щоб
перемогти  мета його мрії,
що наступне номер три, допоможи мені
так, це добре, а Бейонсе так, це
фантастично, я дійсно люблю це,
дякую, зараз прочитайте діалог ще раз я
даю вам 10 секунд, дуже дякую,
давайте йти далі, ви почуєте Брайана
і Стейсі  якщо говорити про книги, які вони нещодавно прочитали,
то чотири речення перше і шосте
послухайте і поставте галочку "правда" чи "неправда", тож давайте ще
раз подивимося на завдання, ми
послухаємо Брайана та Стейсі, і
вони поговоримо про книги, які вони нещодавно прочитали,
то що таке  ми почуємо,
які слова, ймовірно, книги, ймовірно, мені
подобаються, мені не подобається, це дійсно дивовижно,
це приємно чи нудно, а ще,
ймовірно, вони згадають
деталі сюжету, добре, тому, коли
ви послухаєте  Завдання швидко провести мозковий штурм
слова, які ви могли б почути під час
розмови, давайте подивимося на речення,
тому подивіться на речення та
підкреслимо ключові слова номер один
Стейсі щойно прочитала біографію, тому тут у нас
є інформація, біографія Стейсі,
і нам потрібно зосередитися  під час
прослуховування правди чи неправди наступне їй
дуже сподобалася книга, яка ключова
інформація тут, справді подобається книга
знову правда/неправда, ми збираємося
послухати й перевірити номер 3,
вона знайшла кінець трохи повільно, тому ключові
слова  трохи повільно номер чотири інші
рекомендували цю книгу Браяну, тому хто
рекомендував книгу іншим, а Брайану
не Стейсі номер п'ять, йому вона сподобалася
з самого початку, тому йому сподобалася
з самого початку,
а номер шоста він прочитав купу
інших подібних книг  тому багато інших
подібних книг тепер давайте послухаємо та
позначимо інформацію, правдиву чи неправдиву
[Музика]
це 93,2 FM Доброго ранку та ласкаво
просимо до нашого нового щотижневого шоу Big Read, яке
дізнається про книги  наші слухачі
читають спочатку ми маємо Стейсі на
лінії привіт Стейсі що ти
нещодавно читав о, привіт, макс добре я щойно
закінчив читати чудовий історичний
трилер Кейт Мосс Лабіринт CUDA Я
зазвичай читаю біографії або любовні
романи, тому це було щось зовсім
інше  для мене я був здивований, але мені це
дуже сподобалося, сюжет дуже
цікавий, це про двох жінок, які
живуть у різних століттях, але вони
відкривають одну таємницю і намагаються її
захистити, це дуже цікаво, особливо
в кінці, дякую Стейсі,
це звучить як чудове читання  і тепер у нас
є Брайан на лінії Браян, що ти
маєш для нас,
привіт Макс. Я щойно прочитав книгу під назвою «
Поет», тому що всі мої друзі говорили
мені прочитати її, це кримінальний трилер
Майкла Коннеллі про кримінального репортера,
який  Розслідування смерті його
брата має дивовижний сюжет, який
дуже захоплюючий і стрімкий. Я не міг
перестати читати це перший кримінальний
трилер, який я коли-небудь читав, але тепер я  я
хочу прочитати кожну, яку я зможу знайти,
дякую за участь у шоу
, і це все на цей тиждень у великому читанні.
Не забудьте перевірити наступного тижня, щоб отримати більше
чудових рецензій на книги від наших слухачів
[Музика],
тож тепер давайте перевіримо Стейсі  щойно
прочитав біографію книга виправлена
ірно це неправда давайте подивимося на те
ст подивіться пр
віт оцінки я щойно закінчив читати чу
ову історичну Шрілу не бі
графію, тому це неправда да
айте повернемося № 2 їй дуже сп
добалася книга правда  false так, це правда ще раз,
давайте доведемо за допомогою тексту подивіться я
був здивований, але мені дуже сподобалося
добре номер три,
вона виявила, що кінцівка трохи повільна true
false false, тож давайте подивимося на
текст ще раз, він дуже захоплюючий, особливо
в кінці  тож це не може бути повільно. Хороший
номер чотири. Хадас рекомендував, щоб вони поговорили
з Брайаном, чи це правда неправда, так що рекомендація Брайана
[Музика]
так, це правда,
давайте підтвердимо текстом, подивіться,
макс, я щойно прочитав книгу під назвою
po  і тому, що всі мої друзі говорили
мені прочитати її, тому інші рекомендували цю
книгу для читання, давайте перейдемо до п’ятої,
йому сподобалося від початку правда чи
неправда, тож давайте знайдемо інформацію
в тексті, яку
я не міг припинити читати, тому з  на
самому початку він був спійманий і
не міг перестати читати книгу
згадайте фразу з попереднього уроку, я
не міг її відкласти, а останній
він прочитав багато інших подібних книг,
правда чи неправда, знову давайте знайдемо
правильну відповідь  подивіться, це
перший кримінальний трилер, який я коли-небудь читав,
тому жодної іншої книги, ця перша книга
, дякую, дуже добре зроблено, тепер
давайте перейдемо до ще одного завдання, а
ви подивіться, що ви пам'ятаєте про
Стейсі з  текст чи вона читала
книгу біографії чи історичний трилер
ці слова можуть допомогти вам скласти здивований
історичний трилер Кейт Мосс лабіринт
цікавий дійсно сподобався захоплюючий
кінець так швидко скажіть мені, що ви
пам'ятаєте, щоб Стейсі читала
історичний Шріла це написав Камю,
як називається книжковий лабіринт,
добре, вона була здивована з самого
початку, і їй дуже сподобалося,
що ще це була книга має дійсно
захоплюючий кінець і сюжет був дійсно
цікавий,
добре зроблено. Браво, давайте рухатися далі  тож
настав час для вас, я перевірю, чи
ви подивіться,
виберіть правильний варіант для цих двох
питань номер один, що я читав, подивіться
на кримінальний трилер або я не можу записати,
яка правильна відповідь,
це легко правильно  так, це кримінальний
трилер, і давайте подивимося на номер
два, як книга, хм, це нудно або
це фантастичний роман,
що правильно так, це нудно, добре
зроблено, тому для вас є ще одне завдання.
визначення Я збираюся запитати вас
дуже швидко, тому дуже страшна історія
жах Браво
історія кохання романтика історія про
майбутнє космічної наукової фантастики Браво
історія, створена з чиєїсь
уяви
фентезі добре виконані
книги abo  реальні факти та події
документальна література хороша добре відома стара книга
класичний роман
молодець захоплююча книга про
юридичну діяльність злочин Шріла молодець
книга про життя відомої людини
біографія молодець, тому історія, сповнена
хвилювань, екшн і небезпека, пригода
ідеальна зараз  давайте переглянемо ще раз, я збираюся
писати слова дуже швидко, і ви
дасте мені відповідь,
тому FA і TAS чому фентезі добре зроблено, якщо я
бачу, що художня література добре виконана, а b io g RP
hy біографія добре зроблена, тож тепер ваше
домашнє завдання я хотів би  вам потрібно написати п'ять
типів книг, які ви любите читати, і давайте
розглянемо приклад, а потім я
напишу свій власний список, щоб я подивився,
це приклад мого друга,
він дуже любить читати романтичні кримінальні
трилери книги біографії книги в порядку
і наукова фантастика
йому це не дуже подобається, але він
може читати це зараз, я збираюся використовувати
свій неправильний список, і це буде як
приклад для вашого домашнього завдання,
давайте, так що книги я справді люблю читати,
хм  бі  книжки з графіки, де ще
документальна література буде моїм улюбленим,
а
тепер книги, які я люблю читати, не
дуже, але мені це подобається, тому я збираюся
віддати це до серця, хм, добре, це
буде романтика, а що ще
давайте  пригоди та наукова фантастика
Я збираюся піти зі своїми друзями, тож один раз полювати
на наукову фантастику, тож давайте порахуємо один
два три чотири п'ять правильно,
тож п'ять типів книг, які я люблю читати,
ви напишіть свій власний список, і наступного разу
ми перевіримо я чую
дзвонить, і це означає, що нам потрібно
припинити урок, дуже дякую
за урок до наступного разу, до побачення
[Музика]